welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spider-man and after two
weeks of no official statements from
Disney or Sony it looks like we may have
some of the hope that Hawkeye was
looking for with a new report that says
the two companies are meeting this week
to go over some brand-new terms and
conditions this report comes directly
from News website we got discovered who
today ran the story that Sony and Disney
are meeting again this week to try and
broker a new deal that will allow for
both studios to be able to use the
character now last weekend Mike's
certain posted the following status
which seemed to clarify exactly the
standings of each company that state has
said breaking news I am hearing from
sources inside Sony and Disney that both
sides might reach a new agreement in a
week's time more or less contract talks
continue I caution that in business the
smallest differences could result in
this being tabled once again
but for now they seem to be flowing in
the right direction Tom Holland was
given strict orders at recent convention
and not to talk about the Disney story
dispute because he might end up spoiling
sensitive information as I told you
before I joked with Holland personally
when I met him in 2018 and he knows he
has a reputation for talking just to
clarify a deal hasn't been reached yet
however this is the closest they've been
again
brace yourselves should they be enable
the closest now they are going back and
forth at this point it's looking
positive so that's some brilliant news
and what's most interesting about this
is that certain was the person who
originally broke the deal before civil
war and he too reported that
negotiations were failing long before we
had anywhere from deadline that it
looked like Sony were pulling the
character we got this covered back this
statement up today and also said that
Sony are apparently open to the idea
that Marvel can retain use of the
character in their future films and
crossovers however they also wish to be
able to use spider-man in their
films such as venom - and Morbius and
this could potentially open up those
characters to be included in the highly
successful Marvel Universe this might
actually be a response to an earlier
report I did this week that said that
Tom Holland actually filmed a cameo for
venom
however Disney stepped in and made Sonny
cut it as it didn't sit in line with
their vision this was reported by
Collider and Jon Schnepp so it holds a
love weight and seems like it has a lot
of legitimacy to it I'll leave that
linked above so if you want to go check
out the full breakdown of that report
then just click the bottle on the top
now Sony also wish to be able to use the
webhead in any future films such as a
spider-verse sequel and any other
directions that they intend to take the
character into which may include the
highly rumored Cravens last han solo
film i think this deal definitely makes
a lot of sense going forward as at the
time of venom infinity war had just
happened so it would be confusing to see
the character alive again though this
could have tied into a school trip but I
think Disney were right to put their
foot down and say just to cut it however
now it's likely that spider-man will be
around for a while and if he's drafted
back into the MCU then this could
definitely allow him to cross over into
these films without any major issues
being caused I actually think what would
probably happen is that we will see
something similar to the universal and
Hulk deal that Marvel currently have and
have had for the last 10 years which is
that Hulk can appear in crossover films
however he can't appear in solo ones as
Universal wish to retain the rights what
could potentially happen and I have to
stress this is just me making
assumptions is that Sony could going
forward make all solo spider-man movies
Disney may oversee them and help to
produce them and then Disney can use the
character in crossovers such as The
Avengers and more I think this would
massively benefit both companies and
would allow Sony to still use the MCU as
a platform to promote their films as
we've already seen that the extended cup
of spider-man far from home hasn't
really performed as expected and Sony
now may be worried that removing the
character from the universe could have
disastrous consequences again I have to
stress that we haven't had any official
word from Sony or Disney at this point
and that means that negotiations are
probably still ongoing neither company
is stupid and they will obviously both
want to make the most money possible out
of the situation so yeah this makes a
lot of sense going forward I am
she really opened a spider-man being
included in venom and the Sony verse and
think that would be a great idea to
retain the character and also give us
the best of both worlds it's rumored
that we may hear a final decision within
the next two weeks so keep your eyes
peeled for that
I definitely think that's what fans want
and it would be mind boggling to get a
new spider-man film that didn't
acknowledge any of the prior movies or
characters so it just seemed like a
smart move and I hope that it gets saw
it
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on this new so make sure you leave your
thoughts in the comment section below
if you enjoyed this video then please
like it and make sure you check out my
full breakdown of the extended curve far
from home which would be linked at the
end I go over all of the new scenes so
it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more if you want to
come talk to me about movies TV shows
games and comic books then you can
follow me on twitter at definition
whitey it's the best way to get in touch
with me and it's the perfect place to
suggest new videos and content so
hopefully I see you over there after
this also just wanna let you know that
we're giving away a free copy of John
wick 3 on blu-ray and all you have to do
to be in with the chance of winning
instead like this video make sure that
you subscribe to the channel and leave
your thoughts on the sony disney deal in
the comment section below
the winner will be chosen at random on
September the 10th and the Bureau be
shipped out from then till they get
surprised it's the best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]